hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
number 53 q and a section
the cats are voraciously consuming cream
behind us and we are
ready to go to work yes as is the dog
as is the dog very lovely dog
all right we're going to start with two
questions from episode 52.
pick up a question that came off the
discord server that you can get access
to
through either of our patreons and then
move right into the
many excellent questions that we
received last hour before moving into
what i expect
to be a lot of good questions from this
hour all right
first question from episode 52 regarding
externalities could these not be built
into the calculus of consumers as costs
beyond mere dollar value
eating health food in lieu of fast food
for instance social support often
precedes legal support
so why not boycott instead of ban
all right i didn't quite catch all of
that but certainly the goal of those of
us who see
externalities as a major
source of corruption to our system and i
don't mean corruption in
the way that it might sound but i mean a
distortion
in our system something that prevents it
from accomplishing what we would like it
to
is to internalize those costs somewhere
so that they
are born correctly and that the system
evolves in the direction
of eliminating at least the negative
ones which is what internalizing them
would do so
um yes they they have to come into the
equation
someplace and that could be in a lot of
different uh
locations but for example you could
recognize that the cost of using
non-recyclable
materials for example to construct
something that could be constructed out
of recyclable
materials that the cost could be
may it could be internalized by adding
it to the price
of the object rather than
externalizing the harm onto society for
uh
by causing it to lose those influences
so i think anyway
not the clearest answer i've ever given
but the point is yes internalizing them
somewhere is necessary
and i have argued elsewhere that
um internalizing externalities
is if it could be done well and there
are obstacles to doing it well but if it
could be done well it's almost the only
thing
government needs to do in order to cause
the system to work
now obviously you have to do things like
defend the system militarily
against threats but from the point of
view of the system accomplishing the
goals that we wanted to accomplish if
all of the externalities were
internalized
then the market would do all the things
that market fundamentalists
think it does perfect
uh the next the second of two questions
from last episode i meant to have a prop
for and i forgot to
get one so i will just say it says would
you give a tour of your studio
your knickknacks look spectacular and i
thought we could
add a feature where and we show some
object each time that is not perhaps
alive
because he shows up every time yes um
and
uh and say you know 20 seconds to two
minutes about its history but i did not
prepare this time so
um other than grabbing something that's
on stage here we will start that
next time yep we will yeah all right
uh so the discord question this week
is several questions and so i think we
you know we're only maybe going to
answer part of it because
this this is as usual a lot of
a lot of questions can we apply an
evolutionary framework to corporations
can we treat them as memetic organisms
with distinct phylogenys
what regulatory pathways mitigate
consumption and waste what
evolutionarily stable strategies
exist please compare and contrast
existing taxa
so yeah it's it's it's too much it's
more like you know
a couple hour discussion really but just
the first one can we apply an
evolutionary framework to corporations
and maybe
if i may just reframe that further
and say in what way do corporations act
like individuals
and can therefore be said to
potentially respond to evolutionary
pressures like an individual would as
opposed to
like a population yep i would say in
principle
you can the problem is the mapping
so we have the temp the temptation
and many people have tried this and i
don't think it ever works is to view
corporations as if they were critters
right
and the problem is just to say an
individual right yeah they are not
critters
um and they are not critters in many
different ways
for one thing um there's a fact of them
continuing on
through time in a way that critters do
not right the mortality of critters and
the birth of new critters from them and
all of that
creates one set of phenomena and an
indefinitely long-lived critter
is a different thing also you have the
very fact
of people on
boards of corporations being on multiple
corporations
boards simultaneously which causes the
mapping of
what features of the system should
behave in an individual like fashion
not to fit the
the corporate entity very well so as as
you know one of my main
um critiques against the idea of a
corporation being like a critter which
is say like an individual
which therefore would um respond to
evolutionary forces the way an
individual does
is that the members of it and you just
gave the perfect example of this the
members of it
um do not have shared fate in the way
that the individual cells or cell lines
in a body do
right that even um even though you know
a corporation might be said to be more
like a colonial organism than
a an organism like us or hippopotamus or
a cedar tree even um the fact is that a
cell of one cedar tree does not inhabit
simultaneously
a different a different body and you
know you can talk about
you know asexual you know alder stands
and such well then we can get into a
discussion of what makes an individual
individual but if corporations
you know corporation a and corporation b
are distinctly different
and yet they share two members of the
board and all the rest of the board are
also
on other members of the board that just
puts the lie right there to
the idea that they would act um with
you know we're the shared you know with
the understanding of shared fate such
that
if you do wrong by the end by the body
that you are in
you kill yourself along with all of
those who are with you right
and um i would also point out that
sort of a final layer of critique is
that
these corporations which one might model
as critters
contain critters and the problem is that
the critters that they contain
do behave like critters and so
um you know you could i could make an
analogy
though to to say you know given what we
know now about the multitudes that we do
in fact contain
that you know a human individual does in
fact contain critters that are not made
of human
right but this is a little bit more like
a slime mold which
um behaves as a cohesive entity
sometimes and as independent entities
and other times and my point is
if you were to if you were to arrive on
earth as an alien and not know what was
going on
and you mistook the automobiles for
critters you would misunderstand the
automobiles
not because there aren't aspects of them
that behave in a critter-like fashion
but because they contain critters and
those critters you know
one critter driving another critter to
work and dropping them off is not a
reproductive event
right you see what i'm saying so um
no i take that back it's 20. it's not
inherently a reproductive event
yeah that would be a very long car drive
if that all happened in the car but
yeah and dangerous but um
yeah in any case we digress but
the the point is like many things
there's a question of how far does the
analogy go and the problem is
in the case of corporations the analogy
to critter goes
reasonably well but a very short
distance and then it falls apart because
of all the things that go in some other
direction
and there's also um
a question about how to map things
like fitness on to corporations
and anyway frankly we haven't done a
good enough job mapping fitness on the
critters
yes um to pull off the analogy to
corporations but anyway yes there's
something to be done down this road
but doing it well is difficult because
the mapping is so hard
yeah all right first question
from last hour evolution is often
distilled as variation heritability and
differential success
is there a similarly small set of
necessary characteristics for
intelligent
network behavior as in ants farming
fungi
corporations again big mammalian brains
etc
wow um yeah yes almost certainly there
is by virtue of the fact that the
complex
behavior that is so successful at
accomplishing so much
is happening in creatures with limited
capacity to exchange information and
things like that so the basic answer is
there have to be simple rules emerging
from
simple uh from a simple pattern like
that that causes
responsive behavior i mean in effect
that behavior is adaptive
in a different sense than um
evolutionarily adaptive
yeah it is it is adaptive in both senses
but
um the three examples given are
interesting because they're so different
from one another with regard to exactly
this question of shared fate
which i invoked in the last answer right
that we have uh within a brain
a neural network all of those neurons
have precisely shared fate
you know one of them one one of them
sends the brain
into decision making that kills the body
and they all die
uh and the others get very angry at it
for that reason
but it doesn't last long yeah yeah um
ants farming fungi um
is well the ants themselves have a much
closer level of relatedness than they
would if they were not haploid diploid
and all basically full sisters
and so three quarters related to one
another um thus you have
you know a precursor condition that
would seem from those two examples to
maybe be
necessary if not sufficient which is to
say either identical relationship and
perfect shared fate individual
components of a body or in a
hymenopteran haplodiploid situation an
ant b or wasp that has this
genetic situation where full sisters are
actually more closely related to each
other than are any other members of the
population
where you can have the evolution of
cooperation emerging from that
and then corporations in which there is
nothing inherently
uh binding those uh those ties
um except perhaps the
potential for future success yeah
although i mean i think the question
is ask you know in the case of um
leaf cutters farming fungus that are
ants
the question is the behavior that
results in
um i don't want to say optimal foraging
because that's a bugaboo here but
um rational foraging of a forest
so for example you'll have a
nest of these animals in some patch of
forest and they
will send out um some sort of
investigatory party that discovers a
tree that can be harvested and then it's
intensely harvested and then at some
point it stops
paying at a level that would justify
continuing to do it or their
colony has some interest in preserving
the tree and not denuding it completely
or
i'm not sure what exactly but um but the
point is
the ability of an entity that is
basically
it's not totally sessile because they
can move in fact i've seen it once
but um and not armenians but leafcutters
leafcutters on the move i saw uh yeah
hooby on bci
was studying this colony and they moved
their queen
to start in a new place and so you know
this
big fat ant that can't walk is being
transported
to the new place totally wild but um
but anyway the um
the investigating
and utilizing of a patch of habitat
owned by a particular
colony is an you know it's an explorer
mode of some kind
exactly and so the question i think that
the person is asking is uh
what is that explorer mode made of what
are its minimal set of necessary and
sufficient conditions
um it's a good question they're going to
be analogs of the evolutionary ones
because it's an analog of that process
yeah for sure um i guess just one one
more i don't think it's a correction
exactly but you know the actual farming
of the fungus
is not exploratory the collecting of the
leaves which form the substrate for the
farming
um is exploratory but the actual farming
happens within the colony which is
mostly sessile
yeah so absolutely it's a different
phase of the
of the intelligent network behavior if
you will
absolutely all right next question
what came first the primary of existence
what came first the primary existence
before consciousness
or the primary of consciousness primacy
of consciousness before existence
what came first the primacy of existence
before consciousness the primacy of
consciousness
oh this is the kind of chicken and egg
of knowledge versus creationism in
philosophy
do you have thoughts yep so i don't
i want you to start talking because i'm
not sure that i quite i think this is a
pan psychism question
and i would say oh um
okay so pan psychism meaning is the idea
that um
before matter itself there is
consciousness in the universe
and that matter actually evolves out of
a state in which consciousness already
exists and i think there is not
one single credible reason to believe
any such thing and as if that weren't
enough
there is a huge stack of reasons to
believe that it's not the case
and so i think what it is is
a a pressure relief
valve that there are certain kinds of
very high quality minds
and they have a certain zone over which
they accomplish
great things and at the edge of that
zone
they cannot
justify something necessary in other
words what it is basically is
a um jail free card
it is a get out of jail free card for
faith for which one should not
have to have a get out of jail free card
as i have argued to the annoyance of
many high quality thinkers the act of
science requires a tiny little bit of
faith
right you have to have faith that you
exist and you are interacting with the
actual universe and therefore in a
position to say
something about what's true about it and
if that ain't true
everything you conclude on top of it is
nonsense
and if it is true then assuming it
didn't cost you anything and there's
nothing you can do
about establishing it so in that case
you have to just sort of accept this
thing is not grounded in bedrock but
what if you have
a worldview in which everything has to
be grounded in bedrock or it's suspect
and so then you have to come up with
something for the supposed hard problem
of consciousness which
you and i don't regard as a hard problem
but in any case
um you have to explain something about
uh what consciousness is made
of since it's very hard to describe in
fact it may be impossible at this stage
to describe an organization of matter
that
would be conscious so it just happens we
all know it happens because we all
experience it
so is there something more is there
something imbued by the very matter that
makes up the brains that experience all
this consciousness
well no we just haven't explained it yet
it's really not
it's not that kind of mystery but so
anyway i would say
it's yet another black box there's lots
of them yeah and this one you know
i don't i'm not arguing that
consciousness isn't um
fascinating and that it is not a valid
question to say how can matter
have an experience of the universe that
is a that's a good question if not a
hard problem
but um but in any case
the it is like the
worst possible way to answer the
question
occam's razor wise it's like saying
um that because we can't figure out how
this process works
that what fits in the gap is everything
and it's like no you can't you don't do
that it's bad you're just through the
game
the game is to minimize the complexity
of the explanation not to
totally inverted and add everything so
um all right
excellent next question
i am having trouble accepting abortion
other than in cases of rape or incest i
put a very high value in human life
would a mature theory of consciousness
even help given the dilemma of human
life that could have been
yes i have read heather's excellent
essay
yeah this is a tough one yeah it is um
well you want to start off
well i'm not actually i'm not sure
how a mature theory of consciousness
uh does help necessarily
um and maybe it's because i'm not sure
maybe i'm
maybe i'm underestimating what a mature
theory of consciousness could mean
um but for me as i as i think i say in
the essay to which
the person writing is referring
on abortion explicitly
there are many of us who
cherish life and do not
view the sanctity of of
all things that could possibly be
understood to be alive
as the highest value and so even in
organisms
such as anything with human tissue that
could potentially have consciousness
the sanctity of that um does not strike
me
as the the highest value so um
you know personally i don't
think that a newly fertilized zygote
is uh worthy of being called a baby nor
do i think
that a uh an embryo one day from being
born
to a to a woman should be called a
collection of
fetal tissue that is in fact a baby at
that point
so somewhere in that vast middle ground
there there
is an emergence of maybe maybe
consciousness
right so maybe that's what the question
is getting at can we
can we begin to get at when
consciousness emerges
and and look for that as as the
demarcation i guess i feel like that's
even more complicated than what was for
instance written into
into rho originally which was
an attempt to basically look at
viability just you know
physical viability can can
the embryo survive outside of its mother
but
you know so you know that that does seem
to me like a better
a better model than trying to figure out
when it might be conscious
i don't know well i must say i think
viability is
uh there's one defense to be made of
viability which is that in some sense
it's not arbitrary
right on the other hand in another sense
it is arbitrary because
a newborn baby isn't isn't isn't viable
in terms of independent right like you
know a kid
isn't independent kid doesn't depend
until they're like you know i don't know
eight at the earliest but you know
at the very least you know baby can't
even turn over on its own for
many many months so um you know in what
way is it viable well
you know it doesn't immediately
asphyxiate you know up
upon the outside of its mother
terminating terminating yes
right um so yes this this is what i
would say is viability is arbitrary
birth is weirdly arbitrary too um
therefore
and so let me just say i
my position on this has changed maybe
more than any other important
issue that's divisive and i think
what i now understand is
i think there is a lot of reason that
even those of us who are
pro-choice have
got to empathize
with people who have reached the
conclusion that human intervention
is not reasonable under most
circumstances
and the problem is that because
there are two layers of this decision
there's individually where you
philosophically end up
and then there is where we must
collectively draw a line
that any rational person would have to
conclude
is at least somewhat arbitrary so
i want to see that line drawn in a
very justifiable location in other words
i want to
err in the direction of treating
um someone's humanity as important
from long before they can
assure us of anything with their you
know
their action i want to be cautious
drawing that line
partially because it is
in some sense necessary to us living
thinking humans that we not take on
the belief that we are entitled to
interfere with process after process
because there's no
really good argument for not doing it
right in other words
i think we have to extend
the benefit of the doubt here the
problem is
that not being female and therefore not
ever having been
in danger of suddenly being saddled with
a child that i wasn't equipped to raise
or
wasn't inclined to raise at that point
this is to me more abstract than it is
to somebody who's been through that and
so i guess my sense is
a there is a quadrant of pregnancy
in which we can decide that at least
collectively we have to treat this
as a as a choice
right that when you're talking about you
know a single cell
or a a uh you know a blastocyst
right that doesn't have a nervous system
the capacity to feel anything
then is there a moral question
yeah but it's so tiny that it doesn't
rise to the level that
we have a justification in um
interfering with choice and that doesn't
mean that we should encourage people to
treat
it as nothing um but it means
at a practical level it's nothing and
then there's a point at which
i think any reasonable person would have
to agree this isn't nothing
right and in part i mean i think what
the question is getting at is
is not that point to some degree
aligned with the moment at which we
would begin to imagine
that that that embryo is beginning to
develop consciousness
um i don't think consciousness
is what we even mean for one thing we
don't know what consciousness
is at that level and we certainly don't
know how to
spot it reliably in other creatures it
certainly isn't a match
for the definition that you and i have
been using right there can be nothing
you know packaged for exchange
uh at the point that you are you know
unless you're a twin you know at the
point that you're alone inside your
mother's uterus
right so i don't think i don't think
that's
where it is i think there are more basic
questions about a nervous system
that is capable of detecting and
processing
you know pain for example all right
that's uh
you know but we are obviously not a
species that has decided
that causing pain to a nervous system is
something beyond what we might do um
so in any case i i respect
the position of the person who's reached
this conclusion
and i know many many
good thinkers who are given pause by
this very set of issues
but remember that there is a distinction
what we collectively decide the limits
of what's tolerable are
and what one might personally
philosophically arrive at
and uh there
is a safe limit where we can um
keep the moral compromise to a minimum i
believe but i understand people who
don't see it that way
yeah okay change uh
change in topics i put those all near
the top because they were
all kind of about consciousness in part
but also now we're going to move into
stuff around politics in concern to
eric's tweet that you showed on the pond
in concerned eric's tweet that you
showed the podcast and your sentiments
towards it
it filled my heart with joy as a
conservative i think we work better in
tandem
pulling so far from the nucleus of
freedom leads to disaster
so just starting there with a comment
thank you for that
next question do you have any ideas for
how to deal with the consequences of the
proposed
death and of the proposed truth and
reconciliation commission
um i don't know about any modern truth
and reconciliation commissioner at least
i didn't i looked it up
and the first one that came up was um
a nation article from before the
election um
so you can imagine what the slant is but
we're going to need a truth and
reconciliation commission to recover
from trump
about holding a neigh trump and his
neighbor enablers accountable so that's
sort of
the kind of thing i was expecting but
that's from before the election so i
don't know
do you know anything about yeah i've
heard murmurs and i think i've seen that
nation article and i would just say
but again the nation article is not what
this is like the nation article is from
before the election right but how far
before
not i mean not very so i i think it is
the same idea
okay and my point would be this is like
everything else a
bastardization of something important in
order to make
political gains so the whole point of
truth and reconciliation
the whole point is that you have
something that you cannot put
right you cannot go back and pay
everybody for what they've lost right
and so what you do is you agree to a
compromise and the compromise
involves we do not pursue a complete
solution to all that has gone on in the
past because it's unthinkable and it
wouldn't work
and what we do in exchange is we get it
all on the table so we know exactly what
happened
and there are no secrets and that's the
trade so it is a negotiation
and i believe it is very viable and for
the right problem
it is the right solution this is not
that problem because
it is not like apartheid where you know
we all agree that it's wrong you've got
half the electorate
right that thinks that the right thing
to do is to put trump back into office
this is no place for truth and
reconciliation this is actually a
cover story for an attempt to persecute
people for something that you want to
declare
legally bad right and it just it's
appalling
so what i would say is you know okay you
want to take truth and reconciliation an
important process like that that is
necessary from some of the most extreme
atrocities that we know and you want to
kill it off by
capturing it for your own political
agenda like
how bad could your judgment possibly be
yeah next question u.s election came
down to
narcissistic personality disorder versus
borderline personality disorder and
borderline one
which is really worse to live with so
this is
interesting right many people including
us
have suggested that trump is
fundamentally a narcissist and a troll
and he's a political savant in all of
this
um i've never heard biden called
borderline
but if we take it a little bit more
generously and say well maybe the dnc
who have actually won since very few
people seem to
even be talking about biden having one
it's like you know it's it's the bigger
machine
that won um if the democrats won here
um is the dnc borderline effectively
you know again to get back to that
question that came from the discord
server
you can't really talk about an
organization in terms of diagnosis that
apply to individuals
but kind of a little bit
i don't i don't get borderline often
okay i
uh you know it is a parasitic
organism it is a parasitic organism that
has its own objective and it's willing
to sacrifice the body politic
in order to get there and um
you know it has to be
removed it has to be removed surgically
i don't know how but so it's not it's
not a
it's so nakedly self-interested and
consistent in what it pursues
that i just don't i don't understand why
we would analogize it to a
mental disorder so maybe maybe that's
the similarity is that um you put biden
aside for a moment
just who even knows how put biden aside
but remember
where you put him because he won't
um we have commented maybe not on air
before
uh but that harris seems to be if
anything even more so
than uh hillary rodham clinton uh just
just nakedly ambitious and perfectly
willing to take on
whatever whatever costume and she's
being handed at the moment so that she
will appeal most to the people whom she
is in front of
which makes her um a you know nakedly
political
and in an era when you can actually put
a bunch of these moves side by side it
makes her look
like she stands for nothing which i
think she may well stand for nothing
but that flipping of position rapidly
and by circumstance might actually look
like what a borderline person does and i
think the
the incentive the motivation the
ideology is all very very different
but and in fact in some ways yeah you
know borderline human
is impossible to interact with right you
just
there's there's no predicting it and you
and you can't you can't plan around it
um but it is not actually
you know it's not coherently out to get
you whereas this this sort of
naked political ambition uh that
you know harris seems to have and the
dnc seems to have which is about
accumulation of power and resources
only and not apparently particularly
patriotic
is focused and it flips positions
cynically rather than because it
actually holds these uh
things to be true in the moment yeah i
agree but i mean i just think
cynicism is such a cleaner diagnosis and
that yes it will result in a certain
arbitrariness
of position but um yeah
again i think just cynicism so until we
see something that isn't cynical
let's go with cynical let's go cynical
occam's razor says
yeah all right
my concern is that all of biden's
failures over the next four years will
be scapegoated on trump and the gop
the best thing they can do is sit in
vote present and give joe everything he
wants so if when the u.s burns the left
can't avoid culpability
oh there will always be avoidance of
culpability yeah there's there's no
there's no safe place from that now it
is and i just don't think any
simple rubric is going to do i think we
if
things are as it seems that they are we
have elected the dnc
and we both know what that looks like
and don't know what that looks like
because of the new landscape in which
this
horrible cynical uh anti-patriotic
corrupt entity is going to be wielding
power
and delighting and tormenting its
enemies yeah but it is also true that
it's simply politics as usual to blame
your predecessor
on whatever things you don't do well and
to take full credit for those things
that
um that seem to be doing well under your
leadership
but are almost certainly given the time
lags in
the effects of policy um due to someone
who came before you so that you know
that's that's
classic standard nothing special going
on there politics
yep um yeah
i don't know what to say about it i i'm
uh
in some sense despondent watching people
react to this news
as if you know we've hit bottom right
which that that biden's been elected
yeah
that is to say it got as bad as it's
going to get and now
you know it's going to get better
because something reasonable
is back and it's like no this is the
this is the prior crime family okay
right
i understand that given the choices you
preferred this
and congratulations but for god's sake
stop
stop pretending that we've actually
solved a problem here because we didn't
we traded a problem
yeah uh this question came in early last
hour and i think we did address it but
um do you think that we should take the
opportunity to take a look at the
security of our election equipment
a lot of our election equipment is not
tested per nist standards
and is supplied by only three companies
in the u.s yeah
so you you addressed this yeah those
that equipment sucks and um the idea i
mean i remember
back in the day when these machines
first emerged
and dibold a
vehemently partisan
gop aligned corporation
said that they couldn't create a paper
ballot audit mechanism
because it would be unreliable right
sure
dibold one of the leading manufacturers
of atms which
has a paper audit mechanism built into
it
right as if these people didn't know
yeah but that's money that actually
matters i
um yes so yeah these machines are
garbage
i frankly couldn't tell you that they
weren't designed to be garbage
designed to allow people to to influence
elections
and yes nothing could be more important
than us figuring out
how these things work and making a
system that
you know again you may not be able to
make a system that is purely electronic
and is completely
immune but if you think outside the box
and you're willing to combine
features you can build a system that is
vastly more secure than the system that
we have
yep death is the enemy not the other
side
we must understand that we are being
left out in the cold on issues such as
climate change
we will never shame them into letting us
near the heat never shame them
letting us do that we will never we
never be able to successfully we can't
use shame successfully
to let us near the actual and by heat i
think you mean like the actual lovers of
power
um and uh and actually being able to
address the real existential threats
um which include things like energy and
uh yes environment including
including climate change with all of the
questions that reasonable people have
about whether or not the models are
particularly reliable
but um you know habitat loss and
acidification and pollution of air and
water
and um and yes rising temperatures
yep you're on a spaceship and if you
think the demon
is uh the enemy who uh
belongs to the other party you have not
understood what really threatens us and
you're actually putting us in danger i
mean no strongly resonate with that
that's exactly right and it's you know
it it points to to the idea that the
those who seek divisiveness because it
furthers their own careers
right now be it trump or aoc or
anyone else are neither patriots nor
actually interested in solving the
problems they are
it's it's nakedly self-interested yep
yeah autistic people have a hard time
deciphering ad hoc social roles and for
this reason are at greater risk of being
unintentionally offensive
does cancel culture infringe on the
rights of autists are artists the
exception that proves the rule
i don't know what that last question
means but i actually um
i actually have a big think video out
from a couple years ago that
addresses exactly this that so-called
neurodiversity in which people on the
spectrum are included
uh are both people who are neurodiverse
are both more likely to end up creative
problem solving in ways that the system
hasn't seen yet
and yes absolutely more likely to um
to to step on the toes of people without
any
uh without noticing and you know thus be
called out for offense
uh when in fact had no necessarily idea
that that's what they were doing
um and it you know you can make this
argument therefore
that cancel culture is itself um
non-inclusive and not interested in
diversity um
if some of the diversity that you're
interested in is the different ways that
different people's brains actually work
yeah so i guess
the way i would put it is that there's
something about the policing of thought
which is
simply it's anti-dynamism
and you know we should understand that
anti-dynamism
whatever is its source whether it's
mccarthyism
or this woke nonsense whatever the
motivation
is is it is directly targeting the goose
that lays the golden eggs right it's our
dynamism that is our strength
it is our pluralism that allows it to
flourish and for god's sake
anybody who wants to go after that thing
because they know how we're supposed to
think and they're going to force us to
do it
is placing us in danger and uh has to be
certainly kept away from the levers of
power
which video has the most concise and
thorough explanation of brett's
evergreen state college witch hunt
experience
um in
iowa i don't know what iow stands for
what is the best way to share that story
in an easily digestible form
well it's gotta be mike nena
and now mike got a lot of stuff from
benjamin boyce and they are um
friends and have been since uh they have
been collaborators but the thing about
mike's documentary
so benjamin boyce has a like 20 40 part
22 parts much more thorough and it
covers everything and it's beautiful but
you know it's a lot of investment yeah
um
uh mike's is concise and it aligns
but it's still an hour and a half it's
three parts of a half an hour each so
it's still not that concise
right but it's got such relatable
victims sorry so just benjamin's
it's true but the point is compared to
the
hour and a half it's uh anyway
um i would say if you're trying to
forward something to somebody so that
they get a sense for what happened it's
got to be mike's thing if you want a
deep dive it's got to be benjamin's
thing
and i mean also if you're looking for
something written a lot has been written
um but that includes uh what we
wrote actually um in the washington
examiner in
november or december of 2017. yep um
that would be the best written account
yeah so far still
not not it doesn't include everything
but it's 4 500 words which is
both not that concise but also not book
length yeah
yeah please why do teenagers spend time
with their parents
did you ask the suck is your question
yeah okay uh would it be different to
keep the teens out on their own during
these complicated years
are there any examples in nature cheers
and keep doing what you're doing love
from brazil
so um this you know this this gets at
what teenager-ness is and what childhood
is
and looking for examples from nature
presumably from other species suggests
that
anyone else really does the kind of
thing that we do with our extremely long
childhoods and there are other species
with long childhoods but we have the
longest
um uh i think at all but certainly when
you compare
our childhoods to lifespan and we have
we have the longest
yeah and um even in other species that
do have long childhoods
in which there is a period of time when
the children are you know sort of
reproductively viable
uh in theory but mostly still you know
living
living with their parents at home there
is the fact is that the learning isn't
done
the the parenting isn't done and the
childhood isn't done and
um and very often in those cases i'm
thinking of elephants in particular
and you know also the tooth whales like
dolphins
um they they continue one of usually one
of the sexes will stay
um in their natal in their needle family
and one of them will disperse
sort of an inbreeding avoidance
mechanism
so you know do is
is being enclosed in you know a small
space with teenagers when you are the
adults
and you don't you're not living with
extended family sometimes trying
yes zack it is um but no
actually you know we have marvelous
teenagers
and many people we know do because if
you treat them like an alien life form
they're gonna treat you right back like
you're an alien life form but actually
there's a lot of
teaching and learning to be done on both
sides
you're here yeah yeah all right it's
basically right
there's an awful lot of programming to
be
done that's the nature of the human mind
and uh
the the long childhood ain't for nothing
yeah
okay next question two more here and
then we'll move to the next hour
okay thank you is this sam harris tweet
different from the aoc tweet that you
talked about
and if so have you looked up the
definition of sick offense
so i assume i know which tweet it is i
just uh pulled it up but i have not
looked at it yet it reads
there is a needle that we really must
thread successfully contempt for trump
and his enablers in government is a
patriotic necessity
contempt for 70 million trump voters is
a serious error
life is complicated um
i mean he's sam's gotten a lot of
appropriate pushback
for this for this tweet that said
what is the difference contempt which i
like i am not siding with sam's tweet
here i don't think he should have said
it i don't think he should have thought
it
um i don't think this is a a kind or
unifying approach to
the universe and that is not a match for
the the guy that i you know barely know
but uh contempt is different from
forming lists and and
you know am i reading more into aoc's
intentions
as an elected official and reading less
into
sam's intentions without the ability to
wield political power in the same way
maybe maybe i'm being too kind to him
and not kind enough to her
but it is both you know of the same
tenor
and not the same message exactly
yeah i think it is the same instinct
yeah manifesting in a more responsible
and careful form which without still
being
wholly responsible careful i don't think
it is responsible i think it's
uh it's uh over the edge by quite a bit
and you know at some level there's a
basic agreement that we have to be able
to politically
differ substantially and you know
look there is something about
donald trump that is driving sam harris
crazy and it has been from the beginning
right it has been from the beginning
[Music]
but i you know i do think there's uh
a difficulty in being objective i mean
and you know sam
sam and i tangled on twitter yesterday i
guess
where uh you know
i was pointing out he was talking about
how
great it was that the fire hose of
[ __ ] that has been pointed at us for
four years was just about over and i
is this the one where he used the word
[ __ ] no
it's a different one i don't think so um
but anyway i
you know i uh taunted him lightly
pointing out that
we were about to have the fire hose of
[ __ ] turned off and a fire hose of
horseshit
was going to replace it and you know he
can't
see it and his feeling is look you know
i you know i think he said
i'm as afraid as woke of wokeness as
anybody but and i wasn't even talking
about wokeness i was talking about
corruption
yeah and um and the fact is
um we have
a there's something about trump is
almost
like he is constructed
so as to drive sam harris crazy
if you were to create a personal hell
for sam
harris it would involve a dinner with
trump that never
ends right that would be it and it makes
sense too because
you know sam
is as dedicated to being logically
consistent and rigorous as a person can
be
he's as articulate a person as i have
ever
encountered and except in this context
calm right but there's something about
the thing on the other side
that you know it's it's it's like he's
drunk wood alcohol
well he's hardly alone i mean this this
this is what people mean when they talk
about trump derangement syndrome
right yeah this is this is exactly it
that you just
cannot get get over the fact of who the
guy
is and see anything beyond
the you know high high fuel
emotional state that you're just in at
every moment that you're thinking about
him
right but in this case um the
you know so sam came back at me with
let's
get rid of the the deranged maniac in
the white house and then we'll deal with
the influence peddling my feelings you
know what
the influence peddling put the deranged
maniac
in the white house and it put the woke
revolution into the street because what
you have
is a system that is serving certain
interests beautifully at the expense of
the rest of us and
you know by placing the nation in
jeopardy and
these things are all symptoms of that
and so how how can we
deal with the real problem first and
then deal with the influence peddling if
the influence peddling
is what created the whole madness in the
first place so anyway i
am hoping that sam harris will be
restored to us
by the ascension of
the the fire hose of horseshit
replacing the firehouse of [ __ ] but
we'll see
but i mean even
aren't we gonna now for the next two
months to get combined fire hoses
we're gonna have both fire hoses yeah in
a manner of speaking but uh you know
it's only two months
or yeah two months two and a half months
um
one more here before we move to next
hour i think aoc's suggestion of calling
out trumpers by name has some merit
all 70 million of them and likewise
let's compile a complete report of all
73 million identifiable heroic
biden folks oh yeah wow yeah yeah
voter lists not voter registration lists
who'd you vote for list listing styles
it's it's a star belly thing yeah um
that's not it where
we are looking here now all right
we've got a lot of questions this time
we'll we'll read some of the ones that
we don't get today
next time all species have common
ancestors
one strategy for males is to fertilize
as many females as possible
when and why do males know where to stop
why don't all males of all species try
to fertilize all females of all species
i think some do yeah yeah some different
facts
i've also unfortunately met those guys
um
this is echo okay that's great so i mean
there is a serious because that's a
question that's a serious question
yes there is um you know look the point
is
it is competing strategies and
uh the search for a sweet spot between
them
right so if we just take the simple mail
case
we have argued males have two
reproductive strategies one being a
non-investment
reproductive strategy the other being a
high investment reproductive strategy
other is pointing out that there are
three versions of this and i wasn't
going to get into that but one of them
subsumes two of these strategies
it's simply non-investing so
if males are a males have a very hard
time
turning down opportunities to reproduct
to reproduct that's not a thing to
reproduce
when it also makes a terrible opening
line hey baby you want to reproductive
you're right you got to be in a very
specific bar before that one is likely
to land so
um okay so males are
wired so that they can't ignore the
opportunity to engage in reproductive
behavior where they are not being
required to demonstrate an interest
in investment which is why the modern
environment is
so deranging of males and causes them to
behave so absurdly because it seems to a
male who is not paying attention to the
details
it seems to the somatic part of the male
that opportunities to reproduce without
being forced to invest are everywhere
when in fact
uh it's it's it's not happening
but um in the natural
environment that would be a very rare
opportunity for almost every male
and the opportunity to reproduce
actually would come from
a willingness to invest mightily and
females would be favored to force males
to demonstrate that willingness
ahead of time before engaging
reproductive behavior with them so in
any case all this is to say
that a proper
balance between different types of
mating strategies requires
an understanding of how commonly that
strategy
actually is going to succeed in the
world
and so you would expect
under normal circumstances for males to
be biased in favor of the
investment strategy because it's the
only one that typically has a chance of
working
under normal circumstances that don't
involve things like raping and pillaging
during ancient wars etc but
um so the answer is how do males know
where to stop it's a question of males
having
a couple of different routes forward and
what causes them to stop on the route
that you've identified is the fact that
some other route is actually
more productive and therefore more
rewarding yeah and
and males who cross species borders in
their attempt to mate
um those you know those decisions aren't
selected for it because they result in
no
and no kids downstream and uh as for
you know why don't males just try to
mate and you know
try to fertilize all females of all
species there are you know plenty
of good and i'm i can assure you quite
serious pieces of research
involving what like um some moths
and various other flying insects i think
it's mostly
lepidopterans mods and butterflies in
which
i think i think this is right
butterflies can
male butterflies can be induced to mate
with you know something that looks like
anything as long as it smells right
and there are um hymenopteron examples
ants bees and wasps yeah it's actually i
think it's
in the bees and wasps there are
certainly orchids that cause
[Music]
mating behavior in males that tricks
them into
approaching the flower just so that
pollen packets get glued on a particular
place and then the male makes the same
mistake again because after all
he's a male and he goes and mates with
some other flower from the same species
and those pollen packets get distributed
so um anyway that's not the same thing
as everything but yes so
the b doesn't get off but the orchid
does
well we don't know i mean two b's really
get off
i don't know we don't know um we don't
know but look
there's a underlying truth here so these
are drones flying around
uh actually yeah it must be okay
uh but it's at least sometimes it's you
glossing
bees which is gonna be so solitary but
um okay and then the sex ratio in the
glass signs is
yeah in any case the thing is
um absent a requirement of investment
in almost all but not all species
reproductive behavior in males is cheap
and therefore
they are not selected to be highly
choosy about it which will result in
these systems evolving
where some plant tricks a an
animal a male animal into reproductive
behavior that isn't all that expensive
another question from echo are viruses
metasperm
are viruses male by intent and
non-binary by function do they exemplify
toxic masculinity
take care i love you both
not by intent non-binary function but i
don't oh
i but i i feel like i love at least the
third question here do viruses exemplify
toxic masculinity but i have to admit
i'm not sure what it means
well okay there's a look this is so
difficult with you echo
um uh the
the problem i mean there is something
here and the something
involves viruses whatever their origin
and we've talked about this before but
let's say that they are uh sets of genes
that have escaped a genome and have
struck off on their own and so what they
do is they
borrow resources where they infect
right they borrow the resources of some
creature that is
functioning um that
is in some ways like a love them and
leave them
male who is borrowing the reproductive
effort of a female
if you think about a human think about
some
cad human who tricks some woman into
going to bed with them
she gets pregnant he disappears and then
she has to make the massive investment
in the offspring that has been
produced because he's not there to
invest at all right so that
is the kind of uh
propagal parasitism
toxic masculinity yeah
not to put too fine a point on it the
answer would appear to be yes
echo yes ish yes
do you have any insight regarding the
antibody resistant coveted mink mutation
in denmark
uh 12 plus people are sick and much of
the country is locked down
yep oh man i know of it as barely as
is about all um early on there is
thought of
zoonotic um evolution
i guess that's not it's not stenotic
sonic would just be transmission but
um well maybe it is but jumping back and
forth and then back again
with something else i can't remember
what um but the but
it's it's clearly happening in the minx
um oh i guess it was it's
it's been seen in some cats some house
cats but hasn't been observed to go back
yeah same with dogs same with dogs right
so some domesticates and i guess these
minks
are farmed so these are effectively
domesticated as well otherwise how would
you know here's the right
thing and i i should have looked into
this i didn't know the question was
going to come up
yeah one of the back in the early days
of covid where we were discussing lab
league hypothesis that was this year
that was very recently um but still the
early days
back in the day we used to discuss the
lab league hypothesis
and the serial passage experiments that
likely took place in the lab in
presumably training the virus
to be a better model for whatever the
study was that was going on if this was
a lab leak that's the
best explanation is that somebody was
building a virus that would be good for
studying something like how to create
vaccines maybe vaccines that covered
more than one
emergent coronavirus but anyway
one of the questions was and i've now
forgotten exactly why
this question came up but one of the
questions
was could one of these serial passage
experiments have been
in and i think it was mustela's it may
or may not have been minks it may have
been ferrets i don't remember
um but the question
was did somebody
infect a colony of mustelids that is
weasels
and serially passage the virus between
them
because i think it was that mustelids
had
i can't remember was it a spike protein
that was a good model for humans or i
don't know
but uh but in any case if it was the
case
that this is a lab leak and if the lab
in question
serially passaged it through mustelids
then it would be highly likely yeah that
it would
infect mustelids that came into contact
with people like where like a mink farm
yeah and it would not be surprising that
it would then be able to go the other
way because it may already have gone the
other way
yeah right and so um
so that's that's two ifs at the
beginning of that um
but uh you know absent that
it's hard to say because this is
actually one part of that
is something that we spent a lot of time
talking about and you spend even more
time than i did
um on we were talking a lot about covet
the idea that this was
an unintentional lab leak from research
into the virus seems
really very very likely to both of us so
that's a not very big if in our heads
and then the bigger if just
you know in part for me because i just
don't i don't remember the evidence for
or against
is were they doing serial passage
experiments almost certainly yes if it
was lab but were they doing serial
passage experiments with
mink or with mustelids and if mustelids
then
um expecting this to be able to be
bopping back and forth between minks and
humans is not
unexpected that's the thing if this was
a lab leak which seems highly likely
yeah the only
really iffy question in here
is d did the serial you know almost
certainly serial passage experiments
would have
been part of this in fact they would
almost have to be in order for the
evidence that this is a lab leak
uh to be accurate yeah right um
but the only weak link in the chain
is where my stella's involved and
um i certainly again this is you know
people say well why do you need to know
we've got the virus now let's fight it
no this is why you need to know exactly
right this is exactly why you need to
know is that
the uh tissue level promiscuity of the
virus
and the ability to jump between species
are things that would surely have been
altered by such experiments so we need
to know what they were there's just
it it's actually the rare thing about
the epidemiology of this virus
that would have no that that would hinge
in no
way on what the origin of the virus was
uh and that's not to say that we can
point to exactly what the effects would
be
or why um but the idea that it doesn't
matter now let's just
let's just fight the thing it's like we
need to know what thing it is that we're
fighting yeah actually we have to 100
in other news michigan and wisconsin
announced immediate hearings and
committees into voter fraud this morning
just hours before the corporate media
announced biden's victory in unison
color revolution benford's law
and by a conspiracy theorist now so i
had not heard that i did not know that
michigan wisconsin announced immediate
hearings and committees into voter fraud
um boy the benford's law reference
is i someone else brought this up um is
this idea that you can basically
you can see um
created number patterns as opposed to
ones that just happened
because nature tends to produce
numbers that have leading or in some
cases second digits that are more likely
to be
i think it's lowered the lower digits
rather than the higher digits
but there is at least one compelling
i think i did not spend a lot of time
with it master's thesis
um that specifically looks at whether
benford's law i think it's called
benford's law
uh applies to um to elections and
whether or not you can use
the expectation that certain numbers
will appear more frequently than not
in order to discern whether or not
there's been voter fraud or
ballot fraud in elections and at least
in this master's thesis
the author concludes no i don't know
right so you know that's that's just a
lot of a lot of words for one very
particular thing like to spend
does benford's law apply here and could
we therefore use it to find evidence of
voter fraud
maybe it's not clear that we can
that's not clear and you know for me not
having been familiar with benford's law
had heard it a little bit but before
before sort of this week i go well i
want to know the why
behind benford's law before i start
thinking about applying it and all sorts
of
places you know this this does not seem
to me like a fundamental
sort of thing right it's it seems like
an observation of
pattern that itself that that pattern
itself requires explanation
yep um and
presumably those engaged in fraud would
be aware of the law and could
navigate around it so the idea is it's
hard to it's hard to cheat it's hard to
replicate
the actual patterns i don't know okay
yeah
all right so
color revolution
um it's not clear to me why
the yeah why the
uh investigation in michigan and
wisconsin
would be consistent with that but the
color revolution
is a basically
a a subterfuge
used to induce a regime
change in a
uh in a nation and basically it involves
seeding discord along arbitrary
lines causing people to regard each
other as
enemy and topple a power structure
so this is the kind of thing that seems
to have happened in
ukraine i believe and anyway it's the
sort of thing
that has been studied in places like the
school of the americas at fort benning
and
in any case there is a question about
whether the preposterous state of
discord in the u.s
might be such a thing and if so
who is seeding the color revolution are
you a conspiracy theorist
heavens no you are a conspiracy
hypothesis
you are placing these things on the
table they are hypotheses
they make predictions and as long as we
discuss it in those terms it's a
responsible behavior as far as i'm
concerned
hello from cincinnati so are you guys
going to turn your focus back to kovid
soon no one wears masks here
so really so confirmation bias is
through the roof
once seasonal protection is lost we will
be in exponential trouble here
yeah um we should talk about covet i do
think that people being driven and we
were all
collectively lulled into a false sense
of security by the
fact of covid being um
sort of a low-level phenomenon over the
summer
and it's now skyrocketing all over the
place including here in oregon
and which has always had very low rates
especially compared to our neighbors to
the south and to the
north california and washington but is
much higher now um including
daily uh incident rates um than it has
been at any other point
yeah and uh so anyway i'm debating
whether or not to
hold some stuff and introduce it into a
stream where we
talk more extensively maybe that's the
best thing to do
okay but yeah we should uh we should be
talking kobe because
it's back potential solution
trump fights in court for a couple of
weeks if no change concede
but continue legal battles to prove any
fraud if he wins by and instill the
president but corruption will be exposed
if press reports
um well let's put it this way um i
actually
sort of like this scenario best
but wow did they screw up
having the president handle these
allegations and make allegations before
there had been any
uh possibility of tampering
um so or i don't want to say any
possibility of tampering who knows but
um speculating that the election was
going to be stolen was an irresponsible
thing to do
and to the extent that the question
needed to be opened somebody else should
have done it and to the extent that the
question needed to be
revisited as the vote count was going on
somebody else should have done it and by
trump doing it he's complicated the
matter
spectacularly and basically
i do think he has some responsibility to
stand down that dangerous dynamic
um but anyway what you suggest i wish
that thinking had been
in the trump administration from the
beginning and that we hadn't gotten into
such a dangerous position
uh internet troll slash racist gets
people to chant usa
after giving a nazi-esque speech at a
trump rally not sure if this is trolling
sincere or both do you have thoughts see
the speech
at shpancus on twitter i don't know
anything about it
i don't know anything about it i would
say
the sasha baron cohen stunt in olympia
makes me think
one wants to look very carefully at this
video to make sure
that what is being suggested occurred
actually did occur
yeah so i i was very unconvinced by the
sacha baron cohen stunt in olympia
because although
a few people engaged in uh
responsibility yeah nonsense um a lot of
people were booing him and i guess the
point is he went to around
or even if not boeing just started
standing there yeah what are you doing
right right and so
um my sense is when somebody passes your
test
you have an obligation to report that
rather than to focus on those people who
didn't
yes um yes you do yeah
we find morphological symmetry
attractive in a mate but hairstyles
considered attractive are often highly
asymmetrical
thank you men part their hair to one
side etc
hats are often worn at a jaunty angle or
have fruit on one side
i haven't seen a fruit hat in a long
time what's going on here
you know i have i have wondered about
this yeah um because we
um you know this concept of fluctuating
asymmetries
in um in morphology across you know
across taxa across those taxes that are
bilater bilaterally symmetrical
which includes um all vertebrates
uh is is pretty well studied and well
unders
well i don't know about well understood
but pretty well studied and is a real
phenomenon and yet
absolutely hairstyles are
the most the people who are considered
most attractive almost
always have asymmetry in their hair
styles if there's asymmetry to be had
yep
and you know we can take this a step
further to a mole off center
right is yeah you know beauty mark yeah
whereas one dead center is
that's not gonna be it's terrible it's
not gonna be a classic beauty
at any rate right yeah and you know you
know in all of our experience if you get
a zit
on center it's way worse than having to
sit
somewhere right um but
but anyway so i think there are a couple
things to say
one it may be that the asymmetrical
stuff actually highlights the symmetry
right in other words i dare you to try
to get your hair symmetrical
you may have an easier time than i do
but you won't have an easy time right
it's
very difficult to get it exactly
symmetrical which means that to the
extent that it's slightly asymmetrical
and we are symmetry detectors
you know it will set stuff off and
actually it fits maybe with
um the discussion we were having about
the
uh sensitivity of detectors as a
phenomenon becomes rare right yeah yeah
so don't even try
yeah if you know you're not going to get
close just go way off well i mean you
can imagine if you had some very
symmetrical object
against a very symmetrical background
you can almost imagine your brain
overheating looking at it yeah whereas
if you had it against a nicely modeled
you know no pattern kind of phenomenon
it would
sit there and and and the symmetry would
be
all the more evident um no and you would
you would find the places where it
wasn't symmetrical if you've just got
symmetry all the way down
yeah now uh
i had a weird one which was maybe it was
the unheard
podcast which is quite good if you
haven't seen my appearance in the
unheard podcast you might check it out
it was a great discussion
or maybe it was dr phil i can't remember
yes brett was on dr phil this week guys
that actually happened a very weird
phenomenon but
my oldest dearest friend uh texted me
and said i had the strangest dream
you're never gonna you're never gonna
grasp what is going on in this country
with the election
and also brett was on dr phil yes they
sprung on me last minute they
invited me on and i was not sure what to
think i agreed to go on
and then at the last minute they alerted
me to
what the format was who i was going to
be on with
none of this had been mentioned which is
to say for those of you who haven't seen
it i have not seen it yet
uh you were going to be debating a woke
mother of three who's raising her kids
woke was the description
and uh an antifa supporter or just blm
supporter
yeah supporter um and piers morgan
was on um so anyway it was uh and dr
phil
and dr phil and brett weinstein and and
me yes um
but in any case uh somebody i think it
maybe it was even both of those
events they you know they filmed me here
over zoom but they reversed the
direction of the video
so the horse is backwards and i'm
backwards and i have a very
they did that to you i don't think they
meant to i
can't and and you know it's funny
actually that's crazy like that
that messes with everyone even people
who aren't constantly like
having to deal with their own images in
the world right and so i should have
actually you know i think it must have
been dr phil because in the
they have a of course as you as they
would have to they have a crack team of
people who gets the tech
all in line ahead of time and so i had
one of these meetings with their tech
guy and he you know
looked through our camera listen to the
sound and all of that but he kept
telling me could you move a little to
your right and i would move to my right
and he'd be like oh no no
you're left and this happened like three
or four times so something he was
looking at
had to have been reversed oh man um but
anyway
so my point was seeing myself reversed
yeah was it difficult i
and yet what you are seeing is what we
all see
uh well no so are you seeing here
are we saying here what we see in the
mirror
no no we are not yeah we are not
reversed from so you were seeing
you were seeing your mirror your actual
mirror image
right on dr phil on dr phil yeah sure
anyway
yeah so um in short we don't have a good
answer to this no no
i don't remember the question oh no it
was about fruit
we did it was about fruit hats which
they are coming back i promise you
um and it was about asymmetry and the
fact that a little bit of asymmetry like
a beauty mark
or a background of asymmetry might have
some sort of symmetry enhancing
uh effect on the viewer um and
we might like draw attention to the
symmetry and i actually i love the
i love the hat part of this i hadn't i
had thought about in terms of hairstyles
and like there's some hair like
curly hair you can kind of get
symmetrical tightly coiled hair you can
kind of get symmetrical
bangs may be a way but if any part is
showing it is the very rare modern at
least weird person
w capitals weird person who parts their
hair in the middle
yeah if there's a part visible like you
just it's not a thing it's not a thing
no no um you know
i haven't seen a fruit hat since fruit
went organic
right we didn't even ask that it was
rotting into people's eyes
i don't know but uh but in any case yeah
okay we're gonna answer a couple more of
these will trump's loss
cure those with trump derangement
syndrome oh no
or will those with the mania continue
with a new target
both and i would say both and and
i gotta say i'm i do not want to win the
lottery as the
replacement no i think rogan is going to
win rogan is going to win
yeah no that's that's not and there's
obviously different there's different
lotteries for different domains and
there will be some
i mean i don't know i don't know what's
going on in all of the congressional
races and such but i just i don't you
know trump is a one-off figure which is
part of why he's
so hated and so beloved um by totally
different parts of the country
i don't think there's another trump
figure um
but there will but but so therefore they
will lower the bar yet further
and make um even you know innocuous
conservatives who you know speak the way
politicians are expected to sleep
sleep speak into into hitler
yeah into the demons yeah yeah
now that the election is over can we
well
kind of now the election is over can we
please talk about the african-american
crime rate and why it is three times
maybe that's three to five times worse
than the
white one so there's not quite enough
information there
i did see a question from last time that
was asking this that we that
because we had so many questions this
time we didn't address but um i don't
really know
what to say about that briefly here yeah
i don't think briefly is the way to do
it yeah
i think i think it's covered to a small
extent
in the black intellectual round table
those of you who are new to the podcast
you might check out the black and white
time table but there is something to be
said here and this really does get to
the core
difference between modern liberals and
modern conservatives
in terms of what we think the cause of
such a thing is and what might be
therefore done about it so anyway yeah
we should talk about that
i i'd be up for that we need to extend
each other
uh a certain we need to extend some
leeway
and generosity of spirit in order to
have that conversation
uh properly but i think it can be done
and i also think that you really did
talk about it pretty effectively and i i
think it's it's one of also the drums if
i'm not mistaken that coleman hughes
um beats that he talks about am i wrong
about that no no no
uh in fact i would say um there are a
number of
folks on that podcast who glenn lowry
has taken
a what i think is a fairly hard line on
this
and um you know it may be that we
are backed by our various positions in
the world
into seeing things um
one way or the other but anyway i would
love to unpack it so that we can
actually
get to the bottom level and i don't
think we know the answer but i do think
we haven't even properly put the
question on the table and that we should
because the the way out of here involves
going
through there yeah
um there's so many more questions well
we are not going to get to most of them
for which i apologize
i'm worried about the court challenges
leading to a house delegation vote
each state gets one vote along party
lines that ends up 26 to 24
trump and then inferno
uh i don't know enough about the various
challenges and political routes
to a resolution to know if this is
correct but
it's correct yes that would obviously be
that would that would inflame uh
those who those states who voted blue
um because by the states alone
the population in the blue states is far
higher than that in the red states
but of course it's not that the blue
states voted 100 for biden
as we can tell from the popular vote
which is only a couple million
votes different yep so i think what this
is suggesting
is that the result of the court battles
would be to throw
out uh some or all of the
um the electoral college votes from
those states
if the state can't certify then there
aren't enough
electoral college votes available for
either of them to cross 270 which throws
it to the house
i see now the house uh
yeah the house then has to i think the
house then chooses
between the top
three vote getters
um i i i should look into the rules
before i speculate on what they are
um but
um yeah there's no question there's a
disaster
to be had there which is why the unity
movement was so interested
in creating a solution to this problem
that our disaster might cause us to
embrace
um all right i'm looking for just like a
great question to end on here so
i will i'll read the next one in line
and have you start answering it while
while i look for one to end on that
wraps us up neatly or
nicely you have said that a small amount
of genetic transfer between groups
stops genetic divergence what explains
biological differences in humans
in afro-eurasia uh
great question and i just so happen to
have the answer
so and whoever you are you captured the
key thing you were listening very
closely
um braden davis so braden um
the key thing is it prevents divergence
and it prevents divergence
in the case where you do not have
a selection so this the assumptions and
it's fisher's model that we are talking
about
are that a gene frequencies are the same
at the beginning that's the key one and
the one you captured in your question
if gene frequencies are the same a small
amount of genetic transfer keeps them
from diverging in the absence of
selection
so the answer is the
gene frequencies would never have been
the same between europe and asia because
the selective environments and the
arbitrary factors
that had occurred in those distinct
populations
um would have rendered those gene pools
very different and so you're not
talking about the power of gene flow
to prevent divergence you're talking
about the power of gene flow to equalize
divergence which it has very little
power to do
so anyway uh
good job and hopefully that answer made
sense to you
cool okay we're gonna do three more one
of which is just a comment
one when we look at outer space we are
looking inside of the organism we call
universe
two organisms inside our bodies see a
universe a horizon
light i think we can be certain that
they do
they don't have eyes so what in what way
do they are they sensing
the landscape that they're in you know
the organisms inside us are
bacteria mostly so you know
do they do they sense they're
single-celled they don't sense in any of
the usual
senses of the word um still i find it
i find an intriguing philosophical
question
even if the particular instantiation
here doesn't quite work
yep yeah i think unfortunately
creatures a lot more complex than
bacteria
we have no reason to think that they are
more than very sophisticated little
robots
you know things like insects and things
and so you know you have to get to a
fairly complex creature that has a
reason to have a subjective experience
before the question makes any sense and
um
most creatures do not have a reason to
have a subjective experience at all
it just wouldn't serve them which is
part of
why the uh the pan psychism question is
so
galling is that it sort of takes our
experience of the universe which is very
conscious
and imagines that that must be all over
the place rather than it being a really
weird exception in a
place where it has a strange utility but
you know it's kind of a mixed bag too
okay here's just a comment speaking of
corporations as critters i wrote a
fantasy series to that effect with
humans and companies engaging in mortal
kombat for those looking for new
original anti-woke literature
i invite you to check out felima mystic
will
on amazon all right delima mystic
welcome for some reason that
evokes to me the movie brazil
remember the character sam doing battle
with
uh just some sort of oh it's hard to
even say
um yeah yeah okay final question
not an easy one but interesting is there
an ethical difference between
slaughtering a pig
and a dog for food you know
i have raised this very question with
people who have decried
the the
slaughtering of dogs
in certain cuisine traditions
now i think in some sense
there is bound to be a difference
but it is a hard one to draw because a
lot of it involves
understanding what goes on in the minds
of dogs and pigs
so um we have a deal
that's so this is this is where i
already have an answer cemented which so
far sounds
almost completely opposite of yours
opposite of mine until you got to the we
have a deal part where
i think you're gonna we're gonna
converge we have a deal
with with dogs and we have a very
different deal
with pigs exactly um i think we are
breaking
our deal with pigs badly i mean some of
the worst factory farming is
pig farming the way it's done it's
completely inhumane and there's no
defense for it
but that said there is a way to raise
pigs that doesn't violate our deal with
them
and raising dogs for food it takes the
pig deal
and inflicts it on the dog which i think
is a serious betrayal
and um troubled
didn't know you had raised this and i've
never i've never seen
these two things put next to each other
as um
in counterpoint slaughtering a pig for
food slaughtering a dog for food
and it's really an effective way to do
it because we know that both pigs and
dogs are wildly intelligent
and that they can have relationships
with people but
it's exactly it's exactly what you said
that we have we have this deal with dogs
that is in almost every culture on the
planet
and was formulated as a
a friendship an ongoing uh reciprocal
loving relationship that does not end in
one
one of you eating the other yeah uh and
that is
not the relationship you know with a you
know a few pot-bellied pig owners
aside that is not the relationship that
anyone who's been thinking about the
domestication of animals thinks
is the original deal between humans and
pigs and that's not to say that pigs
aren't capable of understanding um their
you know horrible fate they may well be
especially if they're in a factory farm
situation um
but the the deal that we created with
them
is not itself being broken uh
when we engage in some kind of humane
slaughter with them and that you know
that sounds like justification for
murder and that's not that's not what
we're saying
it's that we evolved a different deal
with these two
species yeah i also you know weirdly
this dovetails with the abortion
question from earlier
to me which is you know i was just out
with uh maddie doing some work a couple
days ago
and it did occur to me um
[Music]
you know i actually literally believe i
don't think it has any implication but i
literally believe
we kind of don't deserve the high
quality partner that we got
in dogs that you know at least our dog
is so interested in doing what needs to
be done
and being a team player and you know
and she's so earnest in this regard and
i you know this is a common experience
with dogs rather than
a rarity but in any case
i think when you when you have you know
selected for
and produced a creature that has no
power
over its existence and is
fully on board and actually you know not
just fully on board like
some you know machine that does your
bidding but
you know it's an emotional creature that
actually commiserates with you and
cares about you and really cares what
you think and all that when you've got
when you've created that thing you just
have an obligation to
you know to air in the direction of
being decent to it
and uh so anyway yeah i think the deal
is really built of something
and we we would be wise not to take for
granted the
amazingly improbable thing that we've
got in dogs
yeah because they're they're awesome
they are
i hope the cats didn't hear me say that
i will defend uh defend you to the cats
if it needs to come to that
you think physically it might come to
that no but i think they might little
talking down
all right i don't even think they know
their names i know you don't
they do they do they're just they're
just not talking about it
they're just not talking to you i guess
all right i think we'll stop there um we
will be back
certainly a week from now if not sooner
than that
yeah and i would just say
congratulations to everybody for
reaching the end of this podcast slash
election cycle it's a major
accomplishment and
uh i mean we're not really right there
yet but we're closing in on it and
uh you know well what could possibly go
wrong
well i think that we will be back in
front of this camera and you guys again
before there is complete resolution on
the presidential election we will be
unresolved with you
then when that happens all right we
encourage you to
go to our patreons you can get access to
discord get access to
dark horse membership with private q a
once a month brett did his
uh one of his two-hour monthly
conversations uh for his patrons
we got enough to do this very podcast we
were just cooking along we were having
a lot of great times more than two hours
it was really awesome
um yeah and something else to
say but i don't remember what it was oh
no this is embarrassing
it's terrible um yeah well
if i remember it i'll let you know
somehow
in the meantime be well everyone
[Music]